mais au delà tout ça je pense avoir de
grosses capacités d'adaptation arrivé
ici c'est aussi faire la passerelle
entre toutes les entités qui fusionne de
la ma personnalité caméléon peut
faciliter le bon ding entre toutes les
équipes en place
oui oui oui je me suis renseigné et je
sais que vous êtes sur un beau challenge
alors bon je voulais surtout pas avoir
l'air de pécher par excès de confiance
mais j'estime coché toutes les cases que
c'est affreux j'ai un problème en tout
cas celles indiquées sur la fiche de
klaus je sais c'est parce qu'on a baisé
hier c'est pour ça que 8 ou sexuelles
c'est bien tout ça pendant cette absence
il faut à ce que pouvait m'expliquer le
petit trou dans votre cv l'année
dernière ah oui le trou oui et bien là
bien sûr je sais c'est ça voilà tu es
content tu l'as fait rire et moi aussi
je la fait rire je la fais rire et jouir
de la féclaz fair oui c'est ce qu'on dit
on n'a qu'une vie voix mais si tu les
trouves s'exciter parce qu'elles
rayonnent rectifier le rayonne c'est
parce qu'on a indiqué hier c'est ça le
piège j'ai tout fait pour les
paloumayres du coup tout le monde a trop
désirable moi aussi je suis de viande
mangée par les vôtres oui j'ai dit quoi
que vous étiez désirable
avant je suis désolé je suis super
excité n'ont pas non c'est pas vous non
non ça n'a rien à voir avec vous enfin
cela très bien c'est pas le cas en fait
la vérité c'est que je suis avec
quelqu'un du bureau
alors oui le truc paisible et c'est que
je peux en parler à personne parce que
ça reste secret moi j'en peux plus de
garder sa cacher le sable je veux que ça
se sache
comprenez j'ai besoin que ça se sache
pas comme chez des rats est une bête
sauvage moi regardez moi je voulais
potentiellement tous l'amour je te fais
l'amour tout je te fais l'amour tout je
te fais les motos je te fais l'amour du
sexe à l'état pur
même toi je te fais l'amour le chant et
sa petite cravate et veste qui déboutait
chemise ou ouais j'ai également lu que
30 % des couples sont rencontrés au
travail
cl
regardez elle est là amiens on regarde
quoi si je regarde je saurai qui sait et
si je sais qu'il sait j'aurai pas le
poste puisque personne de la boîte nous
devons le savoir si vous allez chercher
avait pas du tout ça c'est important
pour moi ce post est vraiment exactement
mon profit mais vous avez raison en fait
c'est vrai laissez tomber je vous en ai
déjà trop dit non messieurs
non mais c'est pas du tout mais si j'ai
tout oublié d'ailleurs j'ai écouté même
pas un droit c'est sur ce blog la saison
je ne vais pas vous prendre la chercher
mon havre et je vais vraiment profil
parfait vous êtes super ce que je vous
dis ptom candidat idéal
tout est très bien voilà mais simplement
voilà j'ai bourdes et voilà c'est de ma
faute s'il vous plaît regardez là ça
fait plaisir
regardez là c'est trop tard faites moi
plaisir voilà ce n'est pas que vous la
regardez non je vous n'en sait non je
dis non non non mais sinon non
faites-moi se présentant entre autres
jeunes on va reprendre non mais je suis
arrêté non non je nomme monsieur non
sinon monsieur là non seulement vous de
vous parler de mon réseau je pense que
c'est important de bien connaître le
secteur
cl c'est alice
affirmé qu' hier soir fait n'était pas
bien de quoi je crois que s'il n'y avait
pas des baies vitrées léger mettrai ma
maman ta gueule et coups thalys
on a b x je te laisse trouver une
explication pour les gens du bureau
au revoir monsieur merci au revoir liste
merci beaucoup
pour information vous êtes vous êtes
séparés là
du coup pour le poste ça va être bon
enfin je crois
vous disiez candidat idéal c'est ça